hello my name is rebecca ford and i work
on warframe at digital extremes
today i'm going to be looking over some
of the most
searched warframe questions on google
and hopefully providing answers
first question how big is warframe right
now
right now we've kind of never been on
more platforms so pc
playstation 4 and 5 xbox series x
and xbox one and of course i already
said pc maybe i didn't nintendo switch
so it's pretty big we have a pretty
healthy user base that sticks around and
then we have an even bigger
user base when we release major updates
so you either stick around for the
day-to-day or you come back when there's
something you want to play
and that's been the routine for the past
eight years of my life
so it's only gotten bigger our warframe
accounts cross-platform
did i write this question that could
have been me that did that because
they're not and we really want them to
be and
i'm not surprised this is one of the
most searched questions and i probably
have contributed
to it myself because i would like this
to be the case but they're not right now
are warframe servers down no
they're not we actually have a pretty
good uptime
streak we'll say perhaps i've jinxed it
but no the servers are not down we're
pretty
quick to fix them if they are and that's
actually a big part of my job is
knowing when they're down and because i
haven't had any panics lately
uh they've been up for quite a while so
go go are
warframes human
i can't answer this because i think it's
better answered by playing the game
i think if you're a super fan of
warframe you know the answer
if you've gotten through our cinematic
quest line a sacrifice
you will certainly know the answer to
this and maybe cry a little bit along
the way so
happy crying are warframes sentient
well this is a tricky question because
uh the most important answer that you
want yes or no i can't give you because
you need to play the game to find out
there's a lot to what warframes are
what level of sentience they have and
perhaps
once you discover that you'll feel a
little differently about how
you enjoy your day-to-day warframing who
is lotus well
i know her she's okay even though i
do her voice acting in game she is not
me
she has her own character depending on
where you are in your warframe
journey you either know her as the one
who has awoken you
or you know her as the one who well i
won't say what but
let's just say let's hope 2021 is lotus
arc
we'll have to wait and see won't we who
is space mom
probably me lo space mom is another not
me sorry lotus
space mom is another name for the lotus
it's just a little nickname she's gotten
due to the role she plays
in that early quest line in warframe so
if you've completed the second dream
you'll have a very strong affinity to
the term space mom
and if you've ever watched any warframe
streams you'll probably see spacebomb
get set a lot in chat what
warframe should i get i think to be
pragmatic about this you should get the
warframe that seems to have either the
playstyle you like like invincible and
or support
and or lots and lots of damage or
aesthetically you know if you
really jive with a more sinister looking
aesthetic or a more tech looking one
there's more frames for you
so it's gonna come down to form or
function as with most things
can you explain the warframe nisha
i can it was part of our initial launch
in china we worked with
making two warframes such as wukong and
nezha
who are based on the very very awesome
lore will say of you know chinese
culture and and mythology so neja is
he's fast he's got
fire walking heels he's got divine
spears and
as of you know very recently we primed
him meaning if you like
neja the warframe you can get nezu prime
which is the
ultimate version of this uh very popular
warframe in fact
what warframe is zaku made from
this is a great question um zaku is the
broken warframe that we made in
partnership with our community we
basically said that zaku is actually
made up of
three different warframes that were
broken on a
void mission and zaku is the sort of
culmination of these three frames and
they
as a warframe can't really be taken back
apart and put into these other warframes
that you would know because they're just
you know remnants of of what came before
so i can't tell you
oh no a deer list three
top tier frames in 2021. well there's
lots of warframe youtubers that will
tell you what they think
s tier is uh we recently as in like two
weeks ago released
full stats on what players played with
in 2020 to
give you the usage tiers so what players
actually use the most
for my personal preference right now the
top three tier warframes in 2021 are
probably still mesa just because i like
gunslinging cora has a spot up there for
a lot of reasons but
you could let's say if you wanted to be
just
reliable you could replace cora with
rhino just because it's a very
accessible frame
one of the first frames you get and now
i'm gonna think of the third one
this is tough maybe i shouldn't have
said my own opinion at all maybe i
should have just stuck with the stats
hmm i regret what i've started here my
personal third favorite warfaring this
year is protea
top three protea came out last year in
2020 i think she's great
i think she's super fun really fast lots
of casting
lots of tech tech tech so those would be
my top three uh oh
favorite frame question mark hmm
everyone seems to have a soft spot for
nova she's very cute
very powerful but the true answer is
probably wisp
because she's great and super cute so
probably wisp
tell us something about sevagoth besides
having the best name
in the history of warframe names uh
sevegoth
is going to be a warframe that comes in
update 30 call of the tempestari this
warframe has a very sort of ghostly
energy and from what you know you can
also not only play as sebagoth but you
unleash their shadow as their ultimate
so you get a whole
like ghost experience with their
ultimate that allows you to use a whole
other set of powers
a really fun fact for sevagoth is their
quest
is going to be released this year and
it's going to be it's pretty emotional
and it's going to tell a really great
story about why sevegoth is the way he
is
so i'm very excited how fast
is gauss gauss is you could say the
fastest
if you had to measure it gauss at his
fastest when only using
you know his first ability and fourth
ability combined
not going to give you a figure because i
can't think of it but you can make the
point of this is you can make gauss even
faster if you use other warframes to
buff
his speed so no matter what i say the
answer is
faster than that with creativity so
there you go who is the stalker the
stalker
is the first enemy in warframe that
players encounter and go what the hell
is going on
the stalker appears when he wants to he
is mysterious he leaves after either
being brutally killed by
players with the best gear in the world
or he one shots new players
we can't say more other than he is who
he wants to be
where to find neurodes here we have a
question from someone that's just
starting their warframe journey and
probably trying to craft one of the
first
two things that we put in your foundry
or you get and neuros are on earth
and you can find them in any mission
there if you're lucky kill some enemies
look for some breakable resource pods
and get your neuro let's get farming get
crafting go go go where do you get
argon crystals go to the void it's
purple
it's pretty it's a crystal you'll know
when you get it because the screen will
like pop up and show you that you got
argon crystal so
go get em go to the void favorite open
world
setting in warframe ooh okay we have
three
earth aka planes of eidolon venus aka
orb vallis and infested
body planet aka cambian drift
aka deimos so if you like nocturnal
kaiju go to earth if you like giant
robot spiders go to the orb palace
and if you like disgusting infested
things and
mechs go to damos cambian drift
totally normal game oh my god just how
dysfunctional
is the entradi family in the cambian
drift
well very i would say when you first
meet this
dysfunctional family they kind of all
hate each other but you
uh one of the progression systems in our
open worlds is you like build up
rep with the factions there and the more
rep you build with this family you get
little cinematics of them
perhaps mending their differences so you
can kind of
either just look at them as
dysfunctional or play a part in the
mending it's up to you
but you should do it because you got to
progress what's going on with the duvery
paradox
this answer is rooted in a
2019 reveal that we did at tennocon of a
really really
cerebral weird trailer
for the duvery paradox and basically
haven't said a word since then
and i'm gonna not say a word
are you excited riding alien horses
well the 2019 duvier paradox trailer
showed probably the most insane horse
design in a video maybe not the most
insane but pretty close to like oh my
god what is this horse
i am excited but i'll be real with you
i really we don't we really don't have a
lot to say about this especially uh
not anytime soon so set your
expectations accordingly for a lot
more silence on this topic what's going
on in the glass maker story
oregon vendetta crazy
killer murder mystery boss fight
that's now over and you can no longer
play until we re-release the boss fight
which we are
so some of those words will make sense i
don't know what's new
with the rail jack very well timed
question
uh this answer will vary dramatically
whether or not
update 30 call of the tempestary comes
out before or
after we did a major revisit last year
in 2020
and we're doing another revisit this
year in 2021 that will
make it look and feel very different
from even last year so the answer is
there's always something new
and there's probably always going to be
something changing so just know that
you'll be flying your spaceship around
still
it'll just feel different when is barrow
coming we actually have a bot
that answers this question because we
get asked it so much so
if you're in game just ask when barrow
and the bot will tell you
but the answer is every two weeks
fridays 9 a.m eastern time
who is the man in the wall if you've
unlocked
all the lore in the uh deimos necrolisk
in the back room there's a necroloid
syndicate
and back there there's eight story
entries for the person who we shall say
was the first to meet make his
acquaintance
so the man in the wall was first
acquainted with the world of warframe
through the actions
of one character who you have
only met through their stories so go to
the necrolisk go to the necroloid
syndicate
rank it up read all the lore and then
ask yourself if you still want the
answer to that question because you
may be too terrified to consider the
ramifications of that knowledge
i don't know lastly who is clem
many many years ago the warframe
community
found itself in the adoration of a
community creation known as clem who was
the grineer clone
that just wanted to be a tenno they
wanted to be a warframe they wanted the
warframes to notice them
this grinier clone was shorter he was a
little askew
with his mask and we put him in game
and he is your friend and you can play
missions with him and you can summon him
to help you on your missions and he'll
always be there for you
whether you're in down in the dumps or
having a great day that you want to have
him around
he'll be there so if you play warframe
or maybe you want to get into it
no better time to start it's free to
play we're always updating and we're
going to be
releasing and supporting our 30th update
call of the tempest story which brings a
new warframe quest
new rail jack missions and reworks and a
lot a lot more so hope to see you in
game
pc nintendo switch playstation 4 5 xbox
one and series x so see you later tenno
[Music]
you